with a piece of antiquity now in full
view after nearly two Millennia it's
believed to be the site of the most
pivotal and Infamous moment in the Roman
Republic the assassination of Julius
Caesar now nearly a century after it was
Unearthed the ancient Square known as
Largo Argentina is open to the public
Chris livesay reports from Rome
it's been called the most pivotal
betrayal in the history of the world
it too brutally
Then Fall
marking the end of the Roman Republic
and the beginning of an Empire shall in
these confines with a Monarch's voice
but you could never see the actual place
up close where Julius Caesar was
assassinated the sacred area of Largo
Argentina until now for the first time
the city of Rome has opened it to the
public it was a crime scene yes exactly
but instead of yellow police tape it was
layer upon layer of successive
civilizations keeping it off limits says
Rome cultural heritage superintendent
Claudio Parisi precise the excavation
were made between
1926 1929
but was never possible to go in at the
level of the ancient ground floor now
about 20 steps below street level takes
you more than 20 centuries back in time
thanks in part to more than one million
dollars from the Rome luxury brand
Bulgari the most interesting in that one
just because it has been turned into a
church Jean Kristoff boban is the CEO so
you can eventually discover the four
temples the many of The Monuments
exactly the way they were seen by the
Roman citizens in 400 BC but the
Shakespearean showstopper where Senators
stabbed Caesar to death on the Ides of
March 44 BC well you'd easily Overlook
it Caesar's Heir Augustus had it walled
up and declared a cursed place so that's
where Caesar was assassinated and the
world was never the same yeah yeah and
we have the possibility to identify this
wall because we know from the literary
sources that this room was on the middle
of two toilets and so we discovered the
toilet we know the wall is exactly dead
hold on Caesar was assassinated by the
bathrooms
uh was outside the room but was very
close to this room the toilet blaring
are the ignoble Echoes of the past
but today you can also hear the purrs of
the present the cats have always been
here as we told the time of Julius
Caesar so they have only been here
volunteer Monica baraski takes me inside
the feline Sanctuary that's been amid
the ruins since 1993 after the cats some
Strays others abandoned started
Gathering here can I pet him yes yes
he's very very sweet Cezanne like the
painter yes here they look after and
sterilize them by the Dozen many are
disabled now protected far below were
any Fiat or Vespa can hurt them
such is the Eternal City where life and
history have no choice but to co-exist
you have people walking by you see
scooters buses there's a bus stop right
yes exactly yes the modern city uh go on
and and so the life is not stopped in
that moment this is The Treasure of
Roman for CBS Saturday morning Chris
lives say Rome